Prince Harry and Megan Merkel are back
in Britain for their last official
appearances as senior members of the
royal family the couple returned from
their new home in Canada to attend an
awards ceremony last night it celebrated
the sporting achievements of wounded
service members Roxana Saberi is at
Buckingham Palace Roxana how have Harry
and Megan been received on their return
well as usual there is intense interest
in the couple especially because Megan
hasn't been back in about two months
this time she and Harry are here to say
goodbye at least for now braving the
British weather and a reminder of the
storm of controversies surrounding their
return the Duke and Duchess of Sussex
are back at their first official
engagement since January shock
announcement they're stepping back as
senior members of the royal family but
it's also one of their last Harry and
Megan's say they're not going to step
back from this kind of charitable work
they are gonna stop doing it like this
Sunday Times royal correspondent Roy
anika back cutting ties with doing
charity work on behalf of you know with
the royal families backing but they will
be launching as we know this big
nonprofit organization and I think we'll
see lots of causes and organizations
they support come under that umbrella
being able to serve Queen and country is
something that we're all rightly proud
of and it never leaves us once served
always serving but from April 1st Harry
and Megan will no longer represent the
Queen they'll still hold their titles
his and her royal highness but won't be
able to use them and their recently
launched Sussex royal brand and no
longer contain the word royal Harry and
Megan will give it their best shot and
Harry has wanted a different kind of
life and we know that Megan the royal
life has just not really suited her but
crucially the royal family are leaving
the door ajar
just in case they have any second
thoughts
the couple have other engagements
planned over the next few days today
Harry met Formula One racing champion
Lewis Hamilton and on Monday the couple
will join the Queen and other members of
the royal family at Westminster Abbey on
an official engagement one last time
Roxana Saberi at Buckingham Palace Thank
You Roxana they look like glamour as
they were walking their elegant wolf
Meghan look dazzling she was gorgeous
and shiny and I just think I think
they're happy to be there and I think
they're happy for their next chapter -
yeah they met a Formula One driver I
think they'll meet yeah when they want
to move that's exactly right
we're gonna pick up the phone you're
right no one's gonna turn down that call
all right